[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road 2000s
it's always I'm your driver on this
journey
Caleb Denby and today is gonna be a
pretty interesting day I wanted to start
off by doing a little bit of gloating a
little bit of review on the big match
that just finished up here me against
Jonathan Casey you haven't watched it
you should definitely check it out I was
a lot of fun we had grandmaster Dennis
burrows doing commentary for us and he
did a good job Ben Simon did a good job
commentating and of course the better
player came out on top so with that in
mind I wanted to take a look at what I
thought was the most interesting game
from the match and this is actually the
only game I lost and then after this
game I wanted to go through a little bit
of calculation training what I do what
you can do to calculate a little bit
better and you know because I feel like
that probably played an important role
in this match and you know neither me
nor Jonathan really showed her our best
calculation skills but so okay jumping
into this game efore c6 it was a
caro-kann and let's actually look from
my point of view here we see d4 d5
Knight c3 takes takes Bishop f5 93
Bishop e6 h 4 h6
and it's a mainline caro-kann Bishop d2
the other option for right here is
actually a Bishop f4 move when you can
play Queen a5 check and you know it's
similar positions but like it's kind of
this Queen out on c7 and white is
committing to c4 so you know Jonathan
just went for the a the main option
which is Bishop d2 negative 6
castles Bishop e7 King b1 and then this
is just you know a useful waiting move
kind of forces black to make a decision
with this King and in the game I decided
to go and Castle kingside
this was game one first rapid game so um
what do you think about this line for a
black and white do you kind of know a
little bit about it
what might be going on here so yeah
let's just look at the position right so
you know the the main thing is you know
White Castle this way in black Castle
this way so of course what does that
mean what's white gonna try to do here
when you castle on opposite sides
yeah it's gonna be a game of a pond
storm for white so White's gonna be
trying to break open blacks kingside
like this right and you know a lot of
times and a lot of positions where you
know it's Castleman opposite sides it
becomes just kind of a race where black
thing you know goes this way white goes
this way and whoever gets there first
kind of wins the game
but 'no karo it looks as though you know
white might be really far ahead in this
race right why it has already gotten
this h4 h5 move in for free in the
opening right if we go back we can see
you know h4 here at threaten to trap the
bishop so black had to respond and then
h5 attacked the bishop so black had to
respond again and so you know these are
kind of two free moves for white and
helping out as pawns storm and so if we
get to the current position here you
know it looks as though you know why
it's gonna be ahead in this pawn storm
which is why in the cairo you know first
of all white wants to push the spawn so
he moves this Knight out of the way but
that's why we see this move Queen d5 in
the Cairo it's not a move
you know black doesn't right ahead go
ahead and try and launch a pawn storm
with b5 or a5 or c5 he plays Queen d5 so
what do you think the idea is here what
does black trying to do with this move
and this is still theory I think we were
still in both of our prep
not quite he doesn't want to get rid of
this cuz for one thing you know white
could even consider playing g4 right
away if the only idea was to get rid of
this guy
well yeah that's the other thing it
might you know open up the rook even
further and kind of assist white in his
plan no blacks idea here is much more
you know thematic of the caro-kann as
all CARICOM players know it is an
opening of groveling and begging on your
knees please trade with me please trade
with me into the endgame so my only idea
here is if say you know black does do
something silly like g4 or white does I
want to play Queen e4 and trait Queens I
want to get the Queen's off the board
and then maybe I won't get checkmated
you know one of the main moves here I
think is c4 which runs into this and
yeah it feels like you know I'm somehow
forgetting all my theory but so you know
positions like this where the Queen's
get traded their common and then a the
line that Jonathan shows whoever wants
to keep the Queen's on the board so you
played Bishop III here so he's blocking
off my access to this Queen so already
this puts black kind of in an awkward
spot right and I was aware of this move
I kind of I kind of seen something like
this coming and so black has a few
options here and I played a couple
different ones in the match but and this
one I chose the most offbeat option so
what do you think some choices here for
black might be what would your candidate
moves be
so there's one a pattern that always
jumps to mind right when you see this
bishop come to e3 and this night have
the ability to go here and all kinds of
openings when the pieces are set up like
this you know it's usually it can be a
good idea just to kick this bishop away
right and this is what I did in one of
the games and I think this move is also
okay for black but you know why it's
just gonna drop back in so in the rapid
game I decided to try something a little
bit different
the main move here is actually Queen b5
going even further to try and trade off
these Queens and white usually actually
doesn't capture here because the Sun
game I think is just you know it's gonna
be fine from for black you have these
double pawns but these open files are
gonna be nice for the rooks this pawn
can usually trade itself off for a C
pawn somewhere and the sage pawn is now
going to be more of a weakness than an
asset so usually you would see something
like c4 and a queen a5 check a king a
one maybe c5 here after Knight h4 maybe
this Queen has to draw up all the way
back to h7 and so you know I played them
moves like this
I played blinds like this before I had a
few games a little bit of experience and
I always hated having to put my Queen
back here and I always ran into all
kinds of trouble revolving around it so
against Jonathan I decided to try the
much more offbeat b5 so you might be
thinking okay well white still looks
like he's ahead in this pawn race right
he still has this opponent h5 and you're
still miles away and you'd be thinking
along the same lines of Grandmaster
Denis boros if you're thinking like that
because I think on the commentary is
talking about how might this move is
terrible why it's by far leading the
pawns storm but you know fortunately for
for me white does have some issues to
overcome before you can really get this
pawn storm going a lot of those just
have to deal with the awkward placement
of these pieces if you notice they're
all on light squares which means they
are prime for Knight forks which they
might not be apparent yet
the game but you'll see as we go later
on 95 makes a lot of sense
you know this move weakens this square
and you know 95 also gets out of the way
to prepare for pawns storms I go ahead
and play B for just continuing with my
plan
here we see g4 so you know black really
can't allow this pawn to get to g5 or
else I'm in a lot of trouble so I go for
94 here we see rook D to G 1 and now I
kind of missed a chance to be maybe even
a little bit better in the game black
can already do something pretty
interesting to to liven up the game
first of all what do you think White's
threat is if I just do nothing what's
white gonna do not quite g5 he's not
really ready to play this yet I can just
capture it
f4 yeah that's one idea but he actually
has an even more forcing way to to get F
to get a g5 in he doesn't have to wait
for this up for stuff
so I mean what's a you know what's
stopping this pond from getting to g5
it's the defenders of the g5 square so
he simply removes the defender by
planning f3 so this is White's threat if
I don't do anything about it and this
move and then my knight has to go
somewhere really dumb if I go to g5 now
I am walking into f4 with tempo so I saw
after coming and the way I responded in
the game was actually with rook to b8
you know quite obviously preparing the
sacrifice but I actually had a better
way to go about it in the game that I
missed what do you think it's a very
common Cairo idea
probably the most common CARICOM idea
so the idea of french players make fun
of caro-kann players for because they
take twice as long to do it
well no not quite
probably this sacrifice is a little bit
unsound here it's almost very unsound in
the game but it's kind of hanging on by
a thread in the game so I don't I think
white could defend and we'll take a look
at these positions after what happened
in the game but so come on what's the
most common CARICOM pawn break yeah it's
it's c5 right you know French players
make fun of you because you take it and
two steps and French players always do
it in one and they say why is your
opening so stupid you can do this in one
turn why you take so long but yeah just
c5 here and now the point is what are we
doing on f3
we don't want to move this night right
because we move this night we walk into
this g5 break but you know our counter
play is kind of just fast enough yes he
takes d4 and now our Knights hanging but
so are all of his pieces so I don't
exactly remember how the tactics all
work out here but in the end I think
it's it's gonna be you know close to
equal maybe even better for black so
this was definitely something I missed
in the game so would've been a really
great opportunity to break down White's
Center and kind of slow down this attack
but yeah in the game I did play this
trick a b8 move which is again just
preparing to sacrifice this knight on c3
Jonathan said I dare you to do it he
spent a minute and a half and said
that's all I the calculation I need to
do whereas I spent four minutes on this
move and then it took me another five
minutes to play Knight c3 so what was I
doing with all that time well I was
calculating variations which was maybe
my mistake because if you look after f3
I really don't have any choice here
there's no way I can retreat this Knight
and go on living after g5 happens you
know this is actually probably this is
probably already dead lost so I did
eventually make the correct choice which
was nice c3 but I think one of the main
reasons I lost this game was I I took so
long to do it you know I think I should
have just played it much faster I think
that was my big mistake so what happens
well let's see pawn takes pawn takes and
then the easy one to calculate is King
to c1 does anybody see the mate after
king c1 mate in 1 2 3
M 3 every moves a check we're not doing
Kaspari in yet it's ok so there's no
tricks you just play the most obvious
moves and give checkmate
yeah it's Bishop a3 so yeah I'm sorry
King c1 bishop a3 king b1 only move rook
could be one Bishop c1 only move and
it's checkmate so yeah that's the game
so of course Jonathan plays King a1
instead which is a much harder move to
crack now there's only one move here to
really keep the attack going everything
else is just kind of dead lost so it's
kind of the most obvious move what do
you think rook b2 is actually a little
bit too slow so White's biggest
defensive resource here is he actually
has the ability to get this clean and
right away and this is gonna be a
problem for black if these Queens get
traded so this is a really convenient
way for him to uh defend this mate
threat and you know Queen i5 isn't
really possible because of a knight c6
idea so we need something better than er
it be to something with more tempo
yeah Bishop a3 is the only move to keep
the attack going and here I was actually
expecting Jonathan to go for a draw
because it was looking a little scary
for him I don't I don't know how
ambitious you guys are with the white
pieces here but apparently in Jonathan's
head he said yeah I'm up at night I
should be winning and she just see dick
he didn't care which you know in my mind
I was expecting something like Queen c4
you know I go here he goes here I check
and you know we call it a day I get the
white pieces you know I get to survive
the caro-kann as black it's it's a good
time but he had other ideas in mind so
you know what's the only way for white
to really keep the game going which is
what he did in the game if you don't
want the draw you have to stop Bishop b2
right so it's the only way to really do
that
not quite Knight c4 Knight c4 you're
probably running into some danger
because now after Bishop b2 if your idea
was to capture this piece now you
actually are being checkmated because
there's no Queen c4 I guess you have a
queen a6 or something but let's see I
mean this doesn't seem quite right
something about it does not seem right
among other things maybe I can just
double my rooks Oh interesting
so yeah better than night c4 which I'm
sure Jonathan sees the move he saw it
the first time
yeah Jonathan strands joining us
yeah rook b1 it was actually interesting
I was calculating that in the game but
I'm not sure about it
let's see repeat one maybe I can just
give this check and then you are
planning it to take right I guess I take
back and now you're playing in Queens e4
hmm maybe this is playable actually so
maybe I have to do better than uh
checking you let's see maybe a rook b2
here then of Queens c4 my idea is gonna
be rook to b8 and I guess the point of
what I'm trying to say is if you take
here I'll take back and there was a
point at some point I'm forgetting 93 my
idea was gonna be I want to trade off
one of these rooks and then play Bishop
b2 and go for this endgame but it seems
like I'm a tempo too short to do
something like that
interesting see a rupee one was actually
what I was expecting in the game kind of
well at first of all I was expecting the
drop but if you wanted to play on I was
thinking Rippey one would be a good way
to do it the way he chosen the game was
actually Bishop c1 but I'm interested in
the circu one stuff it's it's probably a
little bit too dangerous after this and
maybe something like this just to keep
pieces on and I'm already gonna be
threatening to do things like this
coming up and c5 as well but maybe
there's a 93 already but 93 or k4 it
would be kind of complicated right but
say yeah Bishop c1 was the most direct
way to kind of counter this Bishop b2
idea and so now there's only one move
for black again to you know maintaining
quality here only one way to keep the
game going
well your your hanging this guy and I
mean obviously not everything is as
clear after this gets taken but it
should be enough right there's even
night see for
so yeah the YouTube chat has got it you
know you got to play rook b2 it's one of
those cases where the bishops more
useful than the rook because if you play
Bishop b2 here let's see I'm I think
White's just going to capture it
and you look at the position similar to
the ones we were just looking at but now
you know whites up a full-piece instead
of just having two pieces four so it's
gonna be you know quite advantageous for
him so we got to play rook b2 here
instead and now again I was expecting
Bishop takes b2 this ship takes b2 and
York v8 and a forced Perpetual there's
no way for white to really avoid the
perpetual at this point I can play
something like 93 I guess but you know
there's no stopping this you can't ever
take this bishop because again this move
is going to be kind of problematic I
think well let's see actually
I'd be interesting but okay I was
expecting a perpetual instead Jonathan
again surprised me you played Queen to
c4 and now once again there's only one
kind of clever way to keep the game
going for black you definitely can't let
these Queens get traded right away
that'd be a huge problem
so it's a kind of interesting in-between
move here so you make a threat stronger
than a trading the Queen's yeah so it's
Rick fb8 and so of course if you know
the Queen trade were to occur white
would look a little foolish this Bishop
on c1 blocks his first drank defense and
gets its King into some trouble so uh
you know I don't know if this was a
surprise to Jonathan but I feel like it
might have been because he played Quincy
for pretty quickly and confidently and
then he kind of paused for a second
after Rick b8 because it I don't know it
was really the only way for black to
keep the game going and I thought he
maybe might have missed it and for the
fourth time I was expecting Bishop takes
b2 and we would agree to a draw once
again Jonathan said no and found an
interesting way to keep playing with
Bishop f4 and now finally I can punish
white for his you know his daring play
keeping the game going avoiding the
draws and there's actually a way for
black to finally gain an edge here you
know after a lot of awkward moves white
his play to avoid a perpetual black can
finally try and gain something
so I have to threaten checkmate somehow
and I missed it in the game I missed
this whole checkmating idea yeah
Jonathan says he saw Rick p8 the whole
time nobody believes um sounds about
right
you got to be a little bit creative here
oh that's probably the real one no but
okay so we already saw this idea with
his Bishop blocking the first rank so
there's actually an interesting way you
can set up a check mating tactic here
using another idea of blocking this
first rank off that's kind of the key
point say Rick be a fish before
sorry any ideas any ideas there we go
okay somebody in the chat has got it I
don't know if he found it or if he had
already seen the game live but it's
actually moving this rook back which is
not quite what you would expect at first
right it's kind of counterintuitive to
move your pieces away from White's King
but the point is now this Bishop needs
to be on this square rather than the
rook
so who sees the checkmate after Queen
takes d5 excuse me Queen takes d5 who
sees the big checkmate
how so well UK you can't do it quite
away quite right away right he just
takes it an interesting idea though only
we can do it with check
Bishop b2 is checked that's correct and
then here the incredible Bishop c1 so
this would have been a you know a great
way for the game to go obviously I'm not
biased at all oh and I'm sorry we
actually have to take this piece first
because if I were to play this here you
could just capture my rook so yeah okay
we have to capture here and then 93
looks like you know the best way to try
to defend and now of course Bishop c1
and no matter how you take well you can
only take with the king because it's
check this would be mate and if you go
the other way now actually it's our
Bishop doing the blockading and once
again the syrupy one is this checkmate
so it was a really neat checkmate
idea that you know I didn't even
remotely come close to seeing in the
game I was already down to four minutes
I was starting to panic kind of but so
in the game I just played kind of the
most natural move I think I just took on
c2 you know with quite a lot of threats
coming so he went ahead and traded
Queens I traded the Queen back and he
played you know kind of the only move
for a cage to just getting this extra
material out of the way before I could
do anything with it so I captured he
captured and I'm sorry I should briefly
mention here white actually has a
winning tactic here that both of us
missed so if you want to try and find it
you're welcome to but so you know in the
heat of the moment both of us we're
moving pretty quickly and skipped right
over this so any idea if you'll notice a
lot of black's pieces are hanging and
there are some threats so it's it's not
kind of it's not really surprising that
a tactic exists but it's neither of us
we're looking for it we're all kind of
focused on getting these pieces off the
board so white could survive
any ideas
yeah just Knight c4 attacks this rook
attacks this bishop no real way to save
both if you do play Bishop be to simply
king b1 and it takes advantage of the
last hanging piece for black and there's
no way to save all your stuff so don't
make kinging pieces cuz then stuff like
that happens but so a rook each wreckage
- instead rather so sorry we saw a 93
followed by wreckage to trade a Brooks
whoops okay that was the end of the game
yep trade the rooks okay
and after c2 it actually is still an
interesting position because if you look
this Rick can't move off the back rank
because of checkmate this knight can't
move anywhere because of Queens and also
checkmate so Jonathan was left playing
with only one bishop here kind of so he
had to find an interesting way to kind
of untangle so he played Bishop f4 which
was good I realized you know I kind of
have to act quickly while White's pieces
are kind of all dis coordinated so I
played f6 and my idea was simply going
to be to try to dislodge this night
before you know it's time had come to
legally move anywhere that didn't hang
checkmate so we see Bishop d2 happen of
course you know he would like to
blockade this pawn right but once again
you know checkmate
so it's actually really awkward for
white to try to get out of this
so Bishop d2 I think is the best way for
him to do it I continue with E 5 we see
Bishop c3 I go ahead to play e4 and now
white was actually just in time with
this bishop so now he has a squared that
he can move this Knight without losing
the game immediately so just in time to
play Knight to b2 and now I can actually
win the game I have another way to to
win here
and so what do you think what do you
think
right is up a piece and full of
confidence at this point however his
confidence is misguided
Jonathan misguided confidence his white
is losing horribly embarrassing Lee
despite his extra piece one could only
imagine the shame white would feel had
he gone on to lose this game but okay so
let me show you what I did in the game
in the game you know of course I'm
thinking I have to make use of these
pawns so I went ahead and attacked this
g4 plum and this runs into Bishop d2 and
now you know why does it chief kind of
the optimal setup once again all of his
pieces can move again you know he can
move this truck up and just collect this
pawn so you know I I let him get his
pieces back in the game
by giving him two free Tempe when
instead I should have opened it up
immediately so how can I just open it up
get my rook in the game faster
okay maybe you three has been suggested
and yeah III is interesting but uh let's
see what if white simply plays the most
natural Roxy to rook G to rather aiming
for the C pawn oh then Queens you got me
there okay what if white plays the most
natural York c1 here and then of c2 I
think I'm just in time to take this guy
without you no repercussions yes indeed
and my rook is thankfully here to defend
my knight so ether he's not quite fast
enough originally that was actually my
plan but yeah the correct move has been
suggested which is f5 so yeah this is
the only way to really get my rook in
the game and so of course I can hope for
G takes that v or takes f5 and now if we
try something similar my group can
actually come over and defend this piece
and then now you know with this extra e
pawn I'm actually going to be creating
like finally too many threats for whites
poor three pieces to be able to handle
and so you know I think black is
actually just winning here not really a
whole lot I think he can do it's tough
to even like suggest an attempt at
defending maybe you want to try
something like this but some play like
work g2 it's a three to follow and once
again none of your pieces can really
move so yeah unfortunate stuff for white
but you know in the game as I said I'm
down to under a minute
I simply played rook g5 with the idea of
f5 next which just runs into Bishop d2
and Bishop c1 so not a very good move I
followed up with Bishop before trying to
switch diagonals here so I got I did get
to clean up this pawn and as well as
this pawn and after the trade I left him
with this night and we're all gonna
ignore what happened on the previous
turn you guys didn't see anything
rookie 4 and it's actually an
interesting endgame so nobody saw that
the night was hanging
on c4 I didn't see it Jonathan didn't
see it nobody in the YouTube chat saw it
it didn't happen so okay this is an
interesting end game and I think
actually it should probably you know be
a draw with with best play but here I
think I played a terrible move which was
King f8 so I was foolishly trying to run
my King over to help you know defend
against this pawn when actually I should
be using it to guard these key squares
back here to keep White's truck out of
the game so I think of just h5 it's
actually a pretty interesting
endgame here maybe Knight takes h5 Nate
and I take say 5 rather and simply you
know h4 and you have to bring this rook
back at some point so let's see Knight
c4 and if you try to do it now you're
actually a little bit too late maybe you
have to come up here but then this and
you know it can get pretty awkward if
you're not careful if you just waste a
bunch of time taking this pawn so that
would have been a lot more interesting
but after King f8 you know I'm simply
way too slow with this especially
because now my King can't read these
squares and the rat can just come in
behind and so in this position I flagged
ran out of time so an unfortunate end to
a super interesting game but yeah that
was the only one I really wanted to go
over the other ones were kind of less
interesting
I hung material Johnathan hung checkmate
and you know checkmates worth more than
material so that's a lot of those games
ended up ending the other rapid game was
actually also kind of interesting but
Wow okay so it spent a lot of time on
that game but the main thing I wanted to
talk about today was what kind of came
into play here all the way back on you
know these moves where I was playing
ninety four and already I'm I'm thinking
about these Knight takes c3 sacrifices
so what I was spending on my time on and
you know in a classical game and a
longer time control game what you should
spend all your time on is you know
calculating here right calculating
variations trying to get to the bottom
of you know
what's what's going on and so in my head
here I calculated for five minutes and I
got all the way actually to this
position this is a position I had seen
in my head going in and I really wasn't
sure what Wight was going to do here so
I said okay you know I think this is
probably White's best try and I think
the best white has here is actually just
gonna be this draw so I'm willing to go
for it I think you know a draws a
reasonable result to expect going into
this and maybe it'll be dumb and try to
play play form or with some line I
really don't see and so uh that's a you
know that's as far as I got in my head
but so you know in a classical game you
know of course you would maybe think
even longer than five minutes five
minutes actually doesn't seem like quite
a lot of time in the grand scheme but
you know what it's a fifth of your time
it's it's or even like a third of your
time more than a third of your time
almost half it's it's quite a lot to
spend so I wanted to talk about you know
how can you get better at calculating
what are some fun ways to get better at
calculating rather than just you know
grinding out the same you know online
tactics or tactics book over and over
again and one way I like to do that is
actually looking at composed studies so
this is one area of chess a lot of you
might not be as familiar with its
composed studies that are meant to be
you know either aesthetically surprising
or you know pleasing or you know
paradoxical even sometimes and so I
wanted to take a look at some studies
from the classic book by Kasparian
domination in 2545 end games so I wanted
to talk about you know what you can do
to try and solve these studies yourself
and okay ignore the winning move that
was just showing the whole time yeah
wonderful
alright so I want to talk about how you
can try and solve some of these studies
on your own and how you can actually do
them in such a way that it does help
improve your calculation so domination
studies are actually pretty good for
this cuz it helps you kind of train
visualization as well train you know the
squares that piece can move to you kind
of have to
be examining all of them right because
their studies and dominations so that
means you know the piece is going to be
left with no squares left to move to
kind of it's not going to be able to do
anything useful so and this in this case
it's going to be a domination of the
night over the bishop this is one of the
first studies in the book it's by H
Madison first name unknown to me but so
let's take a look at it now let's see
how you know we can calculate through
and try to get to the bottom of a
position like this which appears simple
on the surface right there's only like
seven pieces remaining on the board
eight pieces seven pieces I was right
the first time but it actually can get
quite deep so you want to think to
yourself okay
you know this Bishop has tons and tons
and tons of squares right now what can I
do to limit these squares so I move like
this takes away some squares right but
you know I mean it's not gonna be enough
trapped the bishop so you have to
realize okay I need to use these pawns
as kind of you know threats right so you
start thinking of you know the most
natural ways to tick about doing it
right so you try to push your pawn
through he takes your knight and try to
push your pawn through you plays Bishop
d5 so you can calculate in your head
okay so a six bishop takes up seven a
seven Bishop d5 I'm not in time so the
most obvious plan doesn't work so then
you have to start looking for you know
less obvious plans so what can I do to
aid by a pawn and getting forward faster
or slowing down his defense so what do
you think some interesting ideas
if we do something nonchalant here like
Knight g5 maybe blacks King can actually
also just join it and if we calculate we
get here and we're not in time right so
once again we've got to do something
quickly
so YouTube chat has an interesting
suggestion
I'm not gonna tell you you have to find
out yes so yes c6 is an interesting
suggestion so I'm not gonna say if it's
right or wrong cuz you've got to
calculate to find out so what's the idea
with c6 so yeah it blocks the diagonals
so we calculated in the other line the
most obvious line where you just push
the pawn that you know black is just in
time to stop the pun so if we calculate
now we say in our head okay c6 Bishop
takes f7 c7 and then we Queen right so
he can't take our night after c6 so c6
pawn takes c6 pawn a6 Bishop takes f7
pawn a7 and then there's no way for
black to stop the pawn anymore right
because we calculate Bishop d5 if
there's this pawn on c6 in the way so we
say okay so you know we we did it we won
the game right but not quite so we have
to calculate in our head okay what's the
best way for black to try to defend he
can't take her a knight that's well and
good but what can he do to stop the pond
just the most most natural defense for
black so we're at this position in our
head c6 pawn takes c6 a6
yeah that's right
so see take c6 pawn takes a six and then
Bishop f3 is that what you're saying yes
so Bishop f3 there and that's the most
natural defense right so now what
happens if we just push our pawn just a
seven yeah he pushes his pawn he's
defending the eighth square right so you
know already you know it's an
intimidating book right 2500 studies and
but you can think about these things
quite logically right so you see your
only threats and you can then this is
where the calculation training comes in
you look at the specifics and make sure
you see all the way to the end and a
very forcing line and then a you know
try and get to the solution so we have
our next problem right so c6 great we
block the diagonal pawn takes a six
Bishop f3 now we need some other way to
force this Bishop off this diagonal
right so we have these two squares
covered with our King is there any way
we can force this bishop on f3 to step
off the diagonal so we can go ahead and
Queen our pond yeah sorry
yes so we were looking at this but the
bishop comes to here so the bishop can
take and then defend right so we're
looking in our head now looking in our
head
so c6 pawn takes a six Bishop f3 and
then we want to force this Bishop off
this square and hopefully off of the
diagonal so yeah what happens if we just
attack it with our King
if King g3 what does black want to do
yeah I mean he can actually just come
all the way back right you know he's got
a lot of options there so it's not King
g3 we need something that limits his
options
95 attacks both but then simply Bishop
d5 and then we're kind of out of moves
right we can try and hop this night
around but we're not quite in time he
can push through then his bishops
defending so I'll get rid of some of
those arrows so how else can we try and
get her knight to support her upon and
also attack this bishop maybe so
remember were c6 d takes a6 Bishop f3
so looks like somebody Jacob Sanders
thinks he has the solution
blitz bounty champion Jacob Sanders
thinks he has the solution so he might
actually be on a pretty interesting
track so he was saying c6 takes a six
bishop f3 he wants to go Knight g5 okay
so everybody's on board so what's the
only square for the bishop after Knight
g5 yeah he has to go to d5 then I'll let
you try and find his point here he
already said it in the YouTube chat what
his point was but it's a pretty
interesting one
so he wants to bring the night over to
help the pawn in the fastest way
possible
so it's tough to see in your head right
but this is how it becomes calculation
training is visualizing that position
and then keep going deeper down the line
deeper down the line so uh we're at
Bishop d5 right and so we need to help
help our our pawn out somehow using our
Knight
and so we've there's a lot of tactical
motifs in chess right that prevent you
know pieces mobility there's stuff like
pins you know if a piece is pinned it
can't move if a piece is you know
defending something else it can't move
and so in this case the bishop is it's
kind of limited in its mobility right
because they can't step off of this
diagonal because what happens if it
moves off the diagonal and you know like
Knight g5 say Bishop ce2 what would
happen
yeah the pawn the pawn just goes right
so we want to take advantage of this
bishops limited mobility so this Bishop
you know any squares is defending that
aren't on the diagonal they're not
actually defended right because the
bishop can't go there it can't capture
there so yeah that's how you arrive at
this move ninety six which is pretty
interesting right sorry that one step
further down the line now so of course
the bishop can't take for the same
reason this pawn just goes forward and
so you know there's no arrows in real
life chess but it does kind of help us
I'll stay on the same page here so yes
so let's say ninety six and then uh what
if black you know what's the most
natural way for black to continue
there's a couple natural ways so one
thing would be to open up this diagonal
right what if he tries to play c5 so on
c5 what do we have this one's pretty
direct I'm not quite Knight takes
because then this Bishop can defend
against this pawn forever and we're not
going to win right
so what happens all the time in night
end games you get forked right Knight c7
attacking King attacking bishop and then
uh okay let's say King d7 so okay so
we're c6 takes a6 Bishop f3 Knight g5
Bishop d5 96 c5 Knight c7 King bee 7
Knight takes bishop and it looks a
little unclear at first but you know
okay you're studying a pub you're
studying a composed puzzle you can
safely assume that that wine is going to
be winning so ok so you can't play c5
because you win a spaceship if you want
to go that extra step and calculate it
out till until promotion you're welcome
to but for the sake of time we'll just
say that's winning and so he can't take
your knight he can't play c5 so what if
he just tries to run his King in what if
he plays King d7 trying to go and stop
this pawn so what happens King D 7 the
most natural a7 what does black have
there
so the same idea we started with
originally he just opens the diagonal
okay so I don't know if you can see that
still in your head so 96 King d7 blacks
playing c5 here and again you know this
is defended so we can't just play a7 so
we need to find some way to keep that
diagonal shut down using a you know our
Knight
so what do we have 96 King d7
some way to keep that diagonal blocked
if I were to put this position on the
board I guarantee you would find it
instantly so the point is you know
trying to see it in your head see if you
can visualize the black pawn on c6 the
white knight on e6 bat with the black
Bishop on d5 black King on East d7
that's right
you simply block with the knight on c5
and then the pawn has a safe path to
promotion
so let's finally put it on the board so
takes a6 Bishop f3 Knight g5 Bishop d5
the only square for the bishop now this
clever 96 with the dual threat of 97 and
Knight c5 so we'll try King d7 but now
Knight c5 is just in time to keep this
diagonal blocks and after King here
there's no way to stop the pawn so you
know a super interesting study where you
know this King seems out of play but
this Knight manages to do just enough
against this Bishop to keep it out of
the game to promote pawn and if you do
want to take a look at this line let's
see what happens here you know it'd be a
great exercise to try to calculate all
this out as well let's see one might
play king c6 here
and okay I guess if King see six we can
actually just run our King over right so
you can't play King c6 if you try King
c8 trying to catch the pond the other
way I think we simply have just enough
time to capture this pawn so yeah both
lines end up winning I which kudos to
you if you calculated out that night
fork check lion all the way to the ends
what's a you know a foolish expert like
me had to put it on the board so yeah so
this is a super interesting study I have
one more prepared that I picked out but
I thought something that might be fun is
you know if we can put my calculation
skills and your calculation skills to
the test so if you want to give me a
random number between one and two
thousand five hundred and forty five
I'll put it on the board and we'll see
if we can figure it out here in these
last few minutes be quite the test
pick a number been 2044 alright let's
see what we got oh boy big Queens on the
board for this one should be interesting
alright let's see what I can do here got
a queen on a seven a King on a eight a
knight on c 7c pawn on f5 pawn on f4 all
right on d6 Queen on a3 King on g5 all
right let's go
closing the book before I see any
solutions or anything
this is puzzle 2044 for those of you
with the book at home so let's see I
don't even know the theme one good thing
about this book is it gives you the
theme usually prior to the to the puzzle
but let's see here we can already start
calculating some lines right so we're
down to pawns
looks like our counterplay is gonna come
from where it's gonna come from this
King kind of being unsafe right so
what's the most natural way to attack
this King let's see we have a check
right so Marty calculating okay queen up
three there's no convenient way to block
that check right so let's say you know
King V eight and then what happens if I
just give another check and then try to
checkmate what's stopping me there so I
say Queen f3 check King ba Queen b3
check I guess King a8 and then if I give
a check here then maybe he has a block
with a you know queen b8 so let's see
what can we do maybe with our queen on
b3 that we couldn't do before hands hmm
see it's not so obvious you know I'm not
sure if this was a great idea because
these puzzles are really really hard but
you know I thought it'd be fun to try
and figure it out
so let's see any ideas YouTube chat who
composed this one I already closed the
book man I don't know but I can figure
it out 20:44 this was composed by a and
then this is first initial togar t OG ER
in 1962
Queen see one Queen see one's an
interesting idea
so Queen see one stops blacks only check
and tries to make a threat somehow I
don't know if I see the threat off the
top of my head don't know what the idea
is with Queens see one besides you know
just simple defense because if we you
know if we don't make a threat
I think blacks is simply just going to
push this pawn and then that doesn't
really weaken its what I'm saying is
we're not gonna have any zoogs wrongs
here because black can't really weak in
his position if he can still move this
pawn but now that I just said the word
thug out loud maybe I have some other
ideas so let's see oh yeah so the nice
is getting started if any of you were
playing in that you should probably head
on over if you want to stick it out with
me till the end let's see what we can do
here so let's say Queen f3 King d8 and
now my new idea is to stop any checks
black might have so if I play Queen f3
King b8 and I play let's say King h6
black now has to make a move
now I'm noticing maybe just Queen b6 and
there's no way you know black is really
going to be an Zhuge long difficult
stuff
okay I now see the point of queen c1
waiting someone was actually a very deep
idea well it wasn't that deep but it is
an interesting idea more interesting
than they gave it credit for
so queen c1 we actually are making a
threat our thread is Queen h1 and then
after King b8 the only move Queen AJ
check checkmate
so on Quincy one what Queen h3 maybe
black would have you know an f3 in
defense somehow yeah so let's see Queen
C 1 F 3 Queen h1 and that runs into you
know Queen III check we can't really
allow that interesting see I think this
f3 move might shut down the queen c1
idea
so I'm sorry what would you say queen of
three min okay so yeah Queen f3 King b8
Queen h1 that's interesting so it
threatens checkmate and it's stopping
this king a8 move that gave him the
queen bee it's the queen bee eight move
to block her check so Queen f3 King b8
sorry someday Queen h1 and now let's see
how black can try to defend so off the
top of my head looks like he has a check
with a 96 move so 96 check what's the
most convenient way for us to escape
probably it's not going to be king f6
because then there's a queen d4 check
which picks up our night maybe maybe it
doesn't actually
yeah you could take the pawn but that
runs into more checks which is I hate
getting checks I hate this puzzle
terrible pick Ben Simon if you can do it
yes so unfortunately he can't actually
block because this night is helping to
support this square so you know our
queen would be able to capture there
it's an interesting idea though trying
to get the Queen around to block so Ryan
Murphy has some interesting suggestions
let's take a look at what he has to say
so the Queen f3 King b8 Queen b3 King it
check check check
uncheck rather Queen a2 Queen G - King
b8 Queen H 1 followed by Queen h8 so
this is the same position that we just
achieved after after Queen f3
immediately it followed by Queen h1 he
went the long way around but he was also
worried about an f3 move somewhere but
yet I think the only problem with this
line is this 96 move so if we can solve
96 check then I think we've we found the
answer to this to the study so let's see
so Queen f3 King be a queen h1 96 check
where do we want to put our King
if we go to f6 there's this Queen d4
check move but then you know maybe we
can just capture in this night on a on
e6 it's not entirely obvious to me
so 96 let's go with the least you know
natural move king g6 it's not the least
natural but it runs into more night
checks after a night f8 then one lights
on f8 it's already blocking our queen h8
move and I don't really like that don't
really like the looks of that
well we're just about out of time here
actually so we might have to ask for
some help maybe I'll read the solution
give you guys mints
let's see Taco Bell at six has an idea
so ideas Queen f3 King v8 Queen b3 King
it Queen g8 Queen b8 Queen a - 27 Queen
G - can be a queen bee - check King it
Queen h8 Chuck Queen b8 quinolones check
oh that's very very nice he does
everything with check i skipped like
half your variation i think this might
be the same variation Ryan gave okay so
this might be the answer though so this
is actually very interesting I'll let
you take your picture so check King b8
check King a check queen b8 check point
a7 check King b8 check King a check
Queen b8 check Queen a7 check King be
8.88 mate
so yeah this is a super interesting idea
so he does everything with check and
then he gets there in the ends and of
course you know if this happens we have
a variety of ways to win not the least
of which is this fork but as you know
Ryan pointed out himself there is this
f3 move to try and slow us down but yeah
I think the beauty of this composition
is we can actually just take this and
then after came back to b8 we can go
through the same rigmarole
yeah it's an interesting way to you know
achieve Queen age one all over again and
so eventually we do get there
which I guess is forcing a 95 move and
then uh let's see it looks as though we
have the same tactic here with nike5 so
kudos to Ryan Murphy
kudos to Ryan Murphy and Taco Bell at
six who I'm sure also got there
independently but so yeah super
interesting puzzle really quick we're
already over time but let's check it for
correct
well 2044 or let's see yeah Queen f3
Queen B 3 Queen g8 Queen a2
Queen g2 King V a queen bee 2 quean a
quean a quean a one Queen h1 f3 takes
and then you repeat the same line so
yeah awesome job guys you found it and I
didn't yeah super cool geometry but yet
so these are one way I like to Train
calculation and it's a super interesting
and aesthetic way to look at chess and
kind of a new light not a practical
light but you know kind of a beautiful
light and so this is something you know
you can spend your time on
like I said domination and 2545 endgame
studies by Kasparian super interesting
book and a super interesting class
hopefully so thanks for joining me guys
and I'll see you next week on the road
to 2000
you
[Music]